Remember that our primary funding source every
single month is revenue from direct membership's.
People like you, you might listen to a podcast
here or there.
Watch a YouTube clip occasionally catch a
live stream who sign up at join Pakman Dotcom
because of the virus.
We've seen huge levels of cancelations over
the last two weeks.
People emailing me as many as twenty five
a day saying, David, I'm sorry, I've been
a member for years.
I have to cut expenses.
I lost my job.
I'm making half the money I was and I totally
get that.
If you are in a position where a couple of
bucks a month is something you can spare to
support independent media that you like, go
to join Pakman Dotcom and use the coupon code
Fresh Start, which will save you 70 percent
off of the cost of a membership.
We cannot become numb to violent attacks on
our democracy.
We can't do it, which is why we're down to
seven weeks.
But we must continue to cover the things that
Donald Trump is saying and doing that are
completely anti-democratic.
Now, I know we've talked before.
We've become accustomed to this to some degree.
This has been normalized to some degree because
we've been dealing with it for four years.
But we have to resist the tendency to believe
what's going on is even remotely normal.
This morning, Donald Trump tweeted that a
governor overturned the results of the election,
which Trump lost and then cancel.
I guess Trump is referring to the upcoming
Senate runoffs.
It is not one hundred percent clear what Trump
is demanding here, but what we can tell for
sure is that it's completely corrosive and
destructive to our democratic institutions.
This morning, in response to a tweet about
once again Dominion voting systems, Donald
Trump tweeted, quote, Do something, Brian
Kemp.
You allowed your state to be scammed.
You must check signatures and count signed
envelopes against ballots, then call off election.
It won't be needed.
We will all win.
So what I believe Donald Trump is saying here
is manouver the count of signatures and envelopes
which will lead to Trump winning Georgia.
And I guess he means it will also lead to
David Perdue and Kelly Loffler both winning
their Senate races, which now are going to
lead to runoffs.
Trump believes, I guess if the votes are counted
the way he wants them counted, Trump wins
Georgia, Loffler wins Georgia and Perdue wins
Georgia.
And the runoffs are no longer needed.
This is absolutely and totally insane.
Moments earlier, Donald Trump tweeted again,
incorrectly and without evidence that, quote,
We won Michigan by a lot.
He, of course, did not win Michigan.
He lost Michigan to Joe Biden by about one
hundred and fifty thousand votes.
He's just making things up.
Seven minutes prior to that, Donald Trump
tweeted, quote, fake election results in Nevada.
Also, this is absolutely outrageous.
We can't just ignore it.
We have to actually resist that.
This is normal in our minds for the next seven
weeks.
We've got to work hard.
I am know, as aware as I am of it, we have
to still work hard.
It's like pushing a boulder up a hill like
Sisyphus to prevent the normalization of this
insanity.
We've become somewhat numb to the reality
that this is what the US president does every
day, but we really should not become numb
to it for our own sake at some point.
Is this sedition?
Look at the definition.
Sedition is conduct or speech inciting people
to rebel against the authority of a state.
When Donald Trump asks Brian Kemp to overturn,
disregard, not count, certain that ballots
specifically to overturn the will of the people
and change the election results, at what point
do we have to call it what it is?
I'm not calling it treason, but looking at
the definition of sedition.
Is this not seditious behavior?
To some degree, there will never be repercussions.
He has seven weeks left and then he's going
to go.
There will not be repercussions, but we can't
allow this to be mistaken for anything other
than what it is and the the casual way in
which so many people now are just writing
all of this office.
Add Trump's tweeting again.
The country has never seen anything like this
before.
And we can't depart from this era with anything
other than the full understanding that this
is outrageous.
There is nothing normal about it and Trump's
press secretary is participating in it.
And I want to talk about
that next.